I think Sarah Cooper's talented she's a
pleasant woman and she does need the
Trump thing please stop calling her the
greatest political satirist of our time
please stop I like her and I think what
she's doing is fun but please let's not
get hysterical as we always do okay I'm
not mad at her I want her to have all
the opportunities sure I get it but
let's rein it in she would probably
agree with that okay I know everyone
loves her and no one loves me and that's
okay this town does not love me they
don't love me Jerry Seinfeld does not
love me
Patton Oswalt doesn't love me they don't
retweet me they don't care they've taken
no interest in me nor will they and and
I realize that's because of my words and
actions the reason that these people
don't [ __ ] with me is because of my
words and actions my general demeanor my
beliefs and my unwillingness to
compromise them for whatever so I get it
I'm not hating on anyone I want everyone
to do well but it's just what it is and
I have these meetings with everyone and
everyone's like you should have your own
show here's the deal when I when I'm
about to have my own show I will be
called into a room or it'll be a zoom
conference and somebody an executive
will say will you apologize for when you
and Luis Gomez and Nick Mullen did
Sebastian Maniscalco goes to Africa bed
where you basically said and I quote
let's let the Italians cater the
clitoris to me will you apologize for
that and I will go no that is funny and
they will go yeah but now so that's why
I won't have a show it's not going to
happen I won't apologize and then and
then even if I do so if I apologize and
I look you know and I and I go against
everything I believe then they give me
one or two seasons of a show and then
I'm gonna come back to this podcast and
ask you guys to [ __ ] you know like
give a [ __ ] about me after I've just
compromised it's just doesn't it's not
the way it works
I'd love a show I'd love them to let me
do a show or move
but that's not what it's gonna be
they're just gonna give it to people
that lip-sync I miss what Twitter is
it's let you know everybody I'm eats
without tick-tock everybody on tick-tock
and they'll lip-sync let they don'ts
nobody sings their songs nobody writes
songs I mean it's a it's a it's it's
very strange what's going on right now
it's very strange that people are
enjoying people lip-sync things other
people did not as a novelty as like
entertainment it's interesting but the
answer what the younger generation wants
they want to lip-sync they want they
want people that are good-looking it's
all about optics you know what a
good-looking person to lip-sync a song
it was great as if you go on Tik Tok you
just see the white kids dancing trying
to not say the n-word that's the whole
challenge of tik-tok that's the
challenge of tik-tok being a white kid
you can't say the n-word they're like ah
they smile they just got to smile
through the n-bomb I just can't say it
can't say it